we're doing another draft today Chris
we've already done a draft it feels
weird to do a second one but we
typically do in advance of the upcoming
slate of games the most important
matchups for the week so week six most
important matchups that's what we're
gonna do and I have the question for you
to determine the first selection in the
draft okay Daniel Jones and the Giants
faced the Patriots tonight on Thursday
Night Football as we all know Bill
Belichick has not lost to a rookie
quarterback since 2013
who was the rookie quarterback who beat
Bill Belichick Wow
2013 who would be that quarterback back
then gosh this is really gonna frustrate
me who mm I don't even know who the hell
the damn rookie quarterbacks were in
2013 I don't know I give up go ahead
just tell all right good hi he's
thinking about him what if I told you
and you've already forfeited yes what if
I told you think about where I'm sitting
you're in West Virginia and boy you're
not very good with hints no I know Smith
gosh Geno Smith got a victory against
the patients it's so incomprehensible
the possibility didn't even enter your
brain really I was like what jets and
Geno Smith on a nick folk 42 yard field
goal in overtime the Jets did indeed
beat the Patriots alright I got the
first pick and there are plenty of
different ways I can go but you know I'm
gonna start with the obvious one in
light of the injuries that we've been
discussing if you were watching on NBCSN
you saw the little segment we did on the
San Francisco running game and how
potent it's been this year well Jose
Daly's been out now Mike McGlinchey is
out and the Rams are the next opponent
with Aaron Donald Dante Fowler jr. and
this could get ugly Rams offensive line
against our the let me get that right
49ers offensive line against the Rams
front seven that is going to be
something that will decide that game and
I went back and forth on 49ers Rams
until yesterday and when you throw the
call you stick injury on top of the mic
McGlinchey injury on top of the Joe
Staley injury
I think the 49ers are gonna be in for a
long day and I think that's gonna be a
key matchup if the 49ers gonna win that
game they've got
win that matchup yeah it's definitely
scary I mean Kyle shin-chan's gonna have
to do a lot to you know not put some of
those guys in some bad positions or hide
you know the right tackle with certain
run schemes and pass protection and
things like that and of course not
having use check is a big deal but I'm
with you that was one of the matchups I
wrote there and yeah I was debating
whether that would have been my first
pick to go as well I'm gonna go to the
Cleveland Seattle game I'm gonna go
miles Garrett and Olivier Verne inverse
Russell Wilson not only you know I I
didn't want to make it too broad but man
Russell Wilson last week okay that was a
just an absolute unbelievable
performance I mean there's just there's
not many guys in football that have
could have pulled off that game against
the Rams I mean how many times did he
get them out of danger as far as past
protections concerned his ability to
make magic out of some of those plays is
truly truly phenomenal and he was like a
one-man high light show in that football
game but that will be a huge matchup
because Vernon Myles Garrett they're
gonna have their hands full trying to
contain him get pressure on him so he
doesn't make some of these plays like
we'll see here because when he gets
outside the pocket watch out he's just
truly a phenomenal got a phenomenal
player yeah and it's amazing how when
he's in that spot where the walls close
in he can squirt out of trouble so
quickly and make things happen with his
legs you know I was gonna go the other
side of the ball in this game but but
we'll get to a different game but I just
want to mention Baker Mayfield against
the Seattle defense this is such a
critical game for the Browns and for the
Seahawks that they can cement their
their early grip on the NFC West if they
can go to Cleveland and win but the
Browns need this to avoid sliding to 2 &
4 right and Baker Mayfield has looked
sluggish right now it doesn't have that
same pop when the walls close in he's
got some mobility but not nearly enough
and he doesn't have the same
anticipation that guy like Patrick
mahomes has to get out of trouble before
it's too late and it feels like Chris
he's always running for his life when he
takes off and that he's making bad
throws yeah he's throwing off his back
foot he's throwing with funny body
angles and funny arm angles and it
doesn't work for him
the way it works for Patrick mahomes
when he tries to do it so that's a huge
matchup as well whether he can solve the
Seattle defense whether he can be beat
quick with these reads we were talking
about that earlier two juniors double
covered move to the next guy don't wait
for Odell Beckham to come open move to
the next guy and Mayfield needs to
process that information faster all
right I am gonna go next to a game that
isn't gonna get a whole lot of attention
but maybe it should and maybe it will if
the Cardinals find a way to win and that
Falcons defense is so bad right now
and that Cardinals offense showed some
promise last week and with Dan Quinn's
job on the line now and and look even if
he wins in Arizona on Sunday
back-to-back home games against the Rams
and the Seahawks before the bye week
make it very difficult to to create a
strong case that two and six allows him
to continue after the bye but if they
can't put the clamps on this Arizona
offense you could see calamari and
company win their second straight game I
mean and that would be the low point for
the Atlanta Falcons to go into Arizona
and lose to that team with a first-year
head coach a rookie quarterback you've
got the MVP it from 2016 in Matt Ryan
you've got Julio Jones at receiver but
it all comes down to the Falcons defense
can the Falcons defense slow down the
Arizona offense it couldn't get it done
and that's an understatement 53 points
later against the Texans it's a critical
matchup in this game and Dan Quinn's job
may be riding on yeah well the the
Falcons defense stinks you know that's
certainly this I would expect this
almost to be a shootout
I really would because neither defense
is really good and of course the Atlanta
Falcons do still have Matt Ryan and and
of course that receiving core that can
be dangerous so could be a lot of fun
can't really believe you even picked
this game okay of all the great games on
Sunday you talked about the crappy
Falcons versus the crappy Cardinals you
lost that you lost this draft okay
listen I'm trying to give all the teams
some attention I get so many emails from
you didn't talk about the Broncos you
didn't talk about this team you didn't
talk about any I hate to respond to it
while they stink that's why I don't talk
about it right but I found a way to
wedge in a little love for the Falcons a
little love for the Cardinals great
thanks for wasting our time all right so
here we go
now you know how I feel yeah two hours
every day they don't I think
my email okay I'm going to go spaags
okay spagnolo verse deshaun Watson and
the Kansas City Chiefs Houston Texans
match up I mean yes a little bit of a
similar thing I just talked about with
Russell Wilson
but this Kansas City Chiefs team
defensively reeling a little bit after
what happened to them with the Colts
last week Chris Jones he's injured now
you got to deal with deshaun Watson him
running around the Houston Texans even
though not a great offense they do run
the ball and stay patient with it and
they found another guy other than
DeAndre Hopkins in Kendall I mean an
fuller will fuller excuse me to where
yeah I think Steve Spagnola
he's gonna have his hands full in this
matchup but what is he gonna do to slow
down - Shawn Watson in this Texans
attack yeah and this is another one
where you could go to the other side of
the of the the ball and say Patrick WA
Holmes against the Houston defense
because we're starting to see the
formula for slowing down the Chiefs
passing game and mahomes is a little
banged up can the Texans defense
replicate some of the things that they
have seen from teams like the Lions
teams like the Colts yeah the Patriots
dating back to the AFC Championship so I
thought if you're gonna go for one from
that game that's the one that I thought
maybe you would go together - yeah I
thought about it I I'm only saying that
because you crapped on my pick yeah no
yes that's okay well yes I I just you
know I went with two quarterbacks that
are phenomenal and having to stop them
with my first two picks Russell Wilson
deshaun Watson I mean they're just the
they're playing some phenomenal football
right now I'm gonna go to London in part
because I know please yeah that's 15
more emails I'm gonna get you have no
idea how many emails I get every day
from the folks who watch the show on Sky
Sports pointing out something dumb that
you have said and and also they really
want us to go over there and I need to
quit talking about it because the more I
talk about it the more they keep saying
we really want you to come over yeah so
we need to go over and now I'm gonna get
more emails on that - Christian
McCaffrey versus the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers defense yeah back to week two
the Thursday night game and Cam Newton
was injured why didn't they use
Christian McCaffrey more yet 16 carries
for 37 yards so when he did run the ball
he got bottle
up by Todd Bowles and company and if the
Panthers are gonna win this game and
move to four and two and and essentially
deliver an early death blow to the
Buccaneers shot at winning the division
I they need to use Christian McCaffrey a
heck of a lot more than they did and he
needs a more effective when he gets the
ball then he was back in week two again
16 carries for 37 yards two catches for
16 yards no touchdowns he's been
phenomenal in every other game except
that one this is his chance at a little
Redemption this is North Turner's chance
at calling up some plays that use him a
little bit more and get him in space
where he can do his thing but the
Buccaneers even though they don't have a
great defense they were the best that
anyone has been against McCaffrey and
here comes round 2 yeah well they have
some athletic linebackers certainly and
they've seen Christian McCaffrey before
but that's a big matchup you're right I
mean yeah they're gonna use McCaffrey
and and Ken those Bucs linebackers step
up and cover him out of the backfield
and stop him in the run game alright I'm
gonna go with a little bit of a running
back thing too I'm going carry on
Johnson verse the Packers defensive
front front Packers front seven you know
I look at that game and go that's
dangerous for Green Bay I know they're
at home and it's Aaron Rodgers and Green
Bay at home and they're special but the
run defense for the Green Bay Packers is
not good it is a little worrisome and I
was a little surprised Dallas didn't
rely on the run early on in that game
last week a little bit more than it did
but Detroit dangerous in the run game
their offensive line has kind of found
their way it's a pretty good group and
carry on Johnson is pretty damn good
back there toting the rock so I look at
that as being a really big matchup in
this game if the Lions want to pull off
the upset that his success in the run
game will go a long way to that all
right that's it for today's draft on the
matchups to watch for week six you know
there was one more I was going to
mention let me just let me go ahead and
mention it
Carson Wentz in Minnesota yeah in that
noise trying to make his changes at the
line of scrimmage yep that doesn't get
mentioned as much as it should but it is
very very difficult for a quarterback in
that setting to get his message across
to his linemen he's been doing more of
that stuff as he grows in the offense
it's gonna be harder for him on Sunday
that's a big game both for him and for
the Minnesota Vikings
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports